on est là pour appuyer les familles et
individus les entreprises
on est là pour garder notre économie
stable pendant qu'elle est quasiment
totalement arrêtée pour qu'on puisse
reprendre quand on pourra reprendre avec
nous le ministre des finances du canada
bill morneau bonsoir monsieur mono
bonsoir j'ai hâte
monsieur mandant est ce que vous croyez
que la subvention salariale que vous
annoncer aujourd'hui va véritablement
éviter des millions de mises à pied au
canada
nous savons que c'est très important
d'avoir une subvention salariale ça va
assurer une grand nom des gens qu'ils
peuvent être utiles ils tous continuer
d'être avec leur employeur
mais bien sûr on a besoin aussi d autres
mesures c'est pour ça que nous avons
introduit il ya une semaine
l'intervention pour les gens qui ont
besoin d'une réponse d'urgence ça c'est
très important mais avec ça avec une
souvent science à la réelle
nous pouvons avoir une situation où les
compagnies peuvent avoir leurs prix chez
eux et ça c'est très important mais les
entreprises devront atteindre jusqu'à
six semaines pour avoir l'argent
plusieurs ne rompt pas assez de moyens
pour atteindre 6 semaines pourquoi c'est
si long au début ce que je veux dire
nous nous espérons que ça peut être
entre trois et six semaines ça veut dire
que si c'est possible ça va être trois
semaines nous travaillons avec les gens
seraient venus du canada ça c'est notre
approche administrative
nous avons un système qui qui fonctionne
mais ce que je peux dire en sont
aujourd'hui et
et trois ou six semaines on va avoir la
capacité de payer les entreprises pour
pour ce qu'ils ont déjà payé à leurs
employés et ça c'est notre poche nous
avons trouvé le façon aussi tôt que
possible et nous allons continuer de
travailler pour essayer d'avoir pris du
temps pour éviter tout scandale pour
éviter toute faute pour être certain que
l'argent est bien employé est ce qu'on
va savoir quelles entreprises ont reçu
des subventions salariales
le show est important pour nous nous
allons payer les entreprises
après ils nous ont donné l'assurance
qu'ils ont déjà payé les employés ça
veut dire qu'ils vont ils vont avoir une
approche à prendre nous assure et ça
c'est très important mais ça va être
pour tous les entreprises les
entreprises qui sont trop petites les
entreprises d'une taille moyenne ou les
grandes entreprises parce que nous nous
voulons avoir une approche où les
employés peuvent continuer avec leur
employeur
oui mais est-ce qu'on va savoir quelle
entreprise reçoit une subvention
salariale est ce que ce sera publique
annonce est transparent nous maintenons
comme vous savez nous avons fait des
mesures avec avec une séance d'urgence
ça veut dire que dans les dernière sept
jours on va avoir plus de détails dans
les prochaines journées
mais à mon avis est nécessaire d'avoir
une approche qui est transparent et on
va avoir plus d'informations très
bientôt une entreprise qui réengage donc
ses employés mais qui a pas de travail à
leur faire faire parce que l'entreprise
allait fermer cette entreprise-là donc
aura droit à cette subvention salariale
ça veut dire que si une entreprise a une
diminuation de revenus
de 30% en plus il peut avoir la
subvention de salariés ça c'est ça c'est
le chosun proton et de cette façon ils
peuvent avoir une application
on va voir les détails de exactement
comme dans les prochaines journées
je sais que c'est très important et on
va essayer d'avoir une approche où il
pose avoir l'argent très bientôt vous
avez annoncé donc quand on fait total
aujourd'hui il a à peu près pour 250
milliards de dollars de mesures jusqu'à
maintenant la priorité c'est la santé
c'est d'aider les gens mais est-ce que
vous ou vous inquiéter quand même des
finances publiques parce que l'on s'en
va vers un déficit de 150 200 milliards
je sais aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le
temps pour assurer les gens que nous
allons garder notre système de santé
nous allons les protéger et ça c'est
très important nouveau de travail et de
cette façon on va avoir une économie qui
va fonctionner après le crise
donc c'est clair on doit des choses qui
sont essentiels en ce moment nous avons
nous avons au canada où une bilan fiscal
qui est dans une bonne position
ça nous donne le possibilité de faire
des investissements comme ça nous avions
russes d'être dans une situation comme
ça et donc est ce que cette annonce est
ce que vous prévoyez d'autres annonces
d'autres milliards encore les gérard ont
verra nous nous sommes dans une
situation qui est très très dynamique ça
veut dire que nous ne devons être prêts
à faire des choses pour les gens donc on
va être là pour les canadiens et les
canadiennes
on va être là pour les entreprises pour
assurer qu'on peut on pourrait avoir la
possibilité de d'être dans une bonne
position après la crise un dernier mot
les personnes qui ont une demande en
attente à l'assurance emploi seront
transférés selon ma compréhension à la
prestation canadienne d'urgence est ce
que ces gens pourraient donc recevoir
moins d'argent de la prestation
d'urgence qu'est ce qu'ils auraient eu à
l'assurance emploi
ce que je sais deux choses différentes
maintenant on passe temps prestation
d'urgence à une bénéfice qui est
important maintenant dans une période de
crise après après ça si les gens sont
toujours sans travail il peut être dans
notre système de l'emploi science
emplois tant que ça ça peut être appris
mais maintenant avec une situation
d'urgence
il va ils vont être dans notre notre
approche et après notre système donc
pour le temps normal va être là pour
d'accord merci beaucoup monsieur mon nom
de bresse avec vous merci beaucoup